but we start this half-hour with a
development overnight in special counsel
Robert Muller's investigation into
possible links between the Trump
campaign and Russian meddling in the
2016 election the New York Times reports
Muller has asked the White House for
documents related to former national
security adviser Michael Flynn this
would be the first time the special
counsel has asked the White House for
its records it comes after Muller began
using a grand jury the sign the
investigation is intensifying here with
details on that and other aspects of the
investigation CBS News justice reporter
Paula Reed Paula good morning good
morning let's talk about this use of a
grand jury what actually does that what
does that signify here Oh grand jury is
a tool that prosecutors can use it gives
them a lot of opportunities to gather
evidence for example you can subpoena
documents you can subpoena witnesses to
come in and testify under oath and over
time once you gather that evidence then
you can assess whether or not you think
there is enough evidence to pursue
charges and if you do you can then bring
all of your evidence before the grand
jury to get an indictment it
investigative tool really for Robert
Muller how much power does he have and
and I guess broad scope does he have so
all of his power derives from the Deputy
Attorney General Rob goes inside and in
his order appointing Robert Muller he
says that he is the power to investigate
any ties between Russia and the campaign
and anything else that they uncovered
because once you start turning over
rocks in a case like this you never know
what you're going to stumble over one
great example of that is murder of
General Petraeus he was charged with
mishandling classified information that
was a cyber stalking investigation so
wherever this leads Robert Muller can
fall is there any restriction to it
there are some restrictions he has to
have some sort of evidence of a crime
for example people keep asking me about
the tax returns and you get the tax
returns well maybe if he has evidence
that there could be some sort of crime
linked to those documents he can go to a
judge and potentially get a court order
but you can't just go places out of
curiosity there has to be reason to
collect certain certain evidence when
you look at the team that Muller has put
together what does it suggest about the
direction he's going in this is a
powerhouse team decades of Justice
Department experience sterling
credentials but we are seeing are a lot
of people leaving very well-paid
jobs in the private sector and you're
not gonna do that if this is gonna be a
short time thing this is obviously going
to be a long term investigation and when
you look at the type of work these
people have done you see a lot of
white-collar crime fraud that kinds of
things we've gotten any indication
whether the grand jury has heard from
witnesses yet or if they're just
gathering evidence at this point we know
that they've been subpoenas issued for
documents and there have been interviews
of witnesses but it's not clear whether
or not those witnesses have come before
the grand jury or just been interviewed
by investigators we we often hear we've
heard the president a lot talk about the
Russia investigation in any sense
is he at risk when he talks about it
publicly in terms of what what what
advantage that might give the special
counsel it's more of a political
question really legally speaking I don't
think Robert Muller really cares too
much or it's going to be phased what the
about what the president says but
politically a lot of people in the polls
believe that this is a fair
investigation and they do have faith in
Robert Muller so if you're criticizing
him I think in the eyes of voters that
perhaps says more about you than it does
about the investigation can robert
muller call the president in front of
this grand jury this is a really
interesting question because we know
President Clinton he did give testimony
while he did not appear before the grand
jury he really had no choice that was a
unique circumstance but overwhelmingly
the preference for most defense
attorneys is to not put your client in
that situation especially if you think
they're gonna say something that's gonna
cause trouble either by telling the
truth or telling a lie so here the
president is not a trained attorney this
is starting to involve his family so
putting him in that situation it's
unlikely that any good can come of that
and it's look at his defense attorneys
will try to avoid that at all costs
I Paula Reed thanks very much for being
here this morning